Spibidi-bap-bup,
skibidi-bap-bap-bumpi-dai,
bidi-bap-bap-bap-bap-bap-bap.
Wer war der selbstbewusste Mensch, der zum ersten in seinem Song dachte,
weißt du was, fuck it, Lyrics, ich reime nicht mehr,
ich sing nicht über die untergehende Sonne oder das aufgehende Herz, Nein, ich sag , ,,Skibidi-bap-bap-baba-di-bubb",
und das Publikum muss es wiederholen.
Aber gibt's da wirklich so eine Anzahl von Silben, die man benutzt?
Also ,,Skaba", klar, ,, ,,Skaba-di-bu, Skaba-di-bu. Genau wie in einem Dendemann-Song einmal Ra gemacht wird. Und ich dachte mir, das ist ein cooler Laut. Kann man das einfach so machen? Kann man sich einfach als Songwriter entscheiden, so was in Song zu machen? Oder muss man die internationale Rap-Schule besucht haben? Ich weiss nicht, ob du schon mal so Noten von einem klassischen Stück gesehen hast.
Da stehen auch immer so FFPP drüber.
Und das ist im Grunde einfach so Pf, Pf, Pf, Pf.
Aber es wurde irgendwie falsch verstanden.
Lost in Translation ist oft so, dass gute Dinge besser gemeint waren.
Ich glaube, diesen Gang haben fünf Prozent unserer Zuhörer verstanden.
Denn die wissen, das ist fortissimo, pianissimo und Adagio. Adagio ist ein Kerl. Wie geht's dir Florentin? Und erst mal, weil ihr beschwert euch immer zu Recht, dass wir euch nicht mehr begrüssen. Außer in dem Grund haben wir das irgendwann einfach sein gelassen. Wir haben die Fassade fallen lassen. Wir sind einfach wahnsinnig nicht daran interessiert, mit euch zu reden, sondern wir uns selber einfach. Ja, das Problem ist, das Podcast-Ufo ist ja eine lange Aufnahme. Wir haben uns ja damals im April hingesetzt und haben 16 Stunden lang aufgenommen. Ja, und haben wir irgendwann vergessen. Nur Schnitte. Das heißt, wenn wir uns nicht die Mühe machen, immer wieder nach einer Stunde neu anzumoderieren, dann geht es wieder von einfach normal weiter. Also das ist wirklich angeschlossen an vor, ich glaube, sechs Wochen haben wir die letzte Folge aufgenommen. Und damit herzlich willkommen zum Podcast-Ufo. Skabidi-babidi-boop. Herzlich willkommen zur Podcast-Ufo, der ersten offiziellen Podcast-Ufo-Folge, in der, und ich möchte gleich eine der liebgewonnensten Storylines aufgreifen, die die Pufopedia von Anfang an ziert und die ein bisschen untergegangen ist, aber jetzt wieder so ein bisschen aufgegriffen wird. Und zwar, ich sag mal, heute Folge 105 geht in die Annalen der Podcast-UFO-Geschichte ein. Als die Folge, in der Stefan mobil ist. Stefan ist mobil! Ich muss nie wieder gehen, denn es ist da, es ist passiert. Gestern angekommen, das Boosted Board. Ich habe letztens Playboy gelesen und habe in der Playboy gelesen, wie das Boosted Board vorgestellt wird. Was, im Playboy? Im Playboy wurde es vorgestellt als hip und cool und der neue Trendsetter. Vielleicht, ich habe ein Foto gemacht, ich wollte es dir schicken, dann war mir aber zu peinlich, dass du weißt, dass ich Playboy konsumiere. Vor den Podcast-Ufo-Hörern ist es mir aber egal, die Podcast-Ufo-Hörer können alles übernehmen. Aber angenommen, ist was in Playboy steht denn cool oder nicht cool? Weil die Redaktion ist ja cool, aber die Leser sind uncool. Wir schauen es einfach mal an, wir kriegen natürlich jetzt massive Urheberrechtsprobleme. Wenn ich diesen Text hier vorlese, und zwar in der Trends-Rubrik, steht dort Für-Höhepunkte. Mit dem Skateboard den Berg runterfahren ist schon ziemlich cool. Noch lässiger ist eigentlich nur mit dem Skateboard den Berg hochfahren. Mit dem Electro Longboard Evolve One von Evolve in Klammern 1099 Euro sind solche Spitzenleistungen kein Problem. Das Brett schafft 20 Prozent Steigung und 42 kmh Spitzengeschwindigkeit und trägt sie bis zu 35 Kilometer weit. Das reicht für einige Höhepunkte. Das ist der Miniartikel zu Boosterboards in der aktuellen Playboy. Kannst du das nochmal vorlesen? Weil ich dachte mir, Artikel klingen uncool vorgelesen. Wir sind nicht uncool, wir sind ein cooles Podcast-Projekt, deswegen dachte ich, dann legen wir ein Beat drunter. Und wenn du ein bisschen unrhythmisierst, rhythmisierst vorlesen könntest, dann ist das, glaube ich, cooler. Für Höhepunkte! Stuttgart, seid ihr da die Hände! Playboy-Lisou! Mit dem Skateboard den Berg... Das ist Florentin Will, hier kommt er! Mit dem Skateboard den Berg runterfahren, ist schon ziemlich cool, noch lässiger als eigentlich nur. Mit dem Skateboard den Berg hochfahren, hochfahren! Mit dem Elektro-Longboard Evolve One von Evolve in Klammern.
Eintausendneunundneunzig Euro sind solche Spitzenleistungen kein Problem mehr. Das Brett schafft 20% Steigung und 42 kmh Spitzengeschwindigkeit und trägt sie bis zu 35 km weit. Das reicht für einige Höhepunkte. Und ich sag mal so, in genau dem Spirit ist Stefan seit gestern unterwegs, denn er hat sein Boosted Board. Ich hab mir gerade eben Helm gekauft. Ja, nur weil du ihn gerade gekauft hast, musst du ihn noch nicht tragen jetzt. Podcast-Ufo ist sicherer Raum. Safe Space. Mein Arzt hat gesagt, sie müssen den Helm nicht immer tragen, aber es wäre ganz gut. Ich falle oft um, ich laufe auch gegen Wände und mit meinem Boosted-Board bin ich eh die ganze Zeit kontinuierlich gefährdet. Aber ich meine, sorry, aber ganz kurz, du bist doch so groß, du kannst doch bis deinen Kopf auf dem Boden einschlägt, ist doch locker schon der Krankenwagen. Ich kann die Notarztrufen schon, aber trotzdem schlage ich miserabel auf. Ja, das stimmt. Weißt du was, man wird oft die unkreative Frage mit einem gestellt, wenn man groß ist, kannst du gut Basketball spielen? Weißt du was, am besten, ich würde nur Basketball lernen, um dann diesen Move machen zu können. Hey, kannst du gut Basketball spielen? Klar, umdrehen, direkt ein Basketball in der Hand haben und so ein Dankwurf. Ne, ein Weitwurf. All diesen Dreier. Drei Punkte Dank. Den Drei Punkte Dank. Den Klassiker. Das war doch mal ein cooler Move, oder? Das stimmt. Deswegen hast du immer ein Basketball dabei. Ich frag mich schon immer, du hast den immer so ein bisschen unangenehm. Ich dachte schon, das ist ja deine Trichterbrust.
Aber nein, es ist ja Basketball, den Stefan
Titzel immer dabei hast. Und die zwei Tennisbälle,
falls jemand mal wieder fragt, hast du
Tennis gespielt? Hast du Bock auf ein Court zu?
Ja, diese ganzen
Tennis ist auch nicht cool, ne? Da sagt man nicht, ey, lass mal
kurz ein bisschen kicken. Oder diese
geflügten Begriffe, diese Kosten.
Lass mal kurz ein bisschen Fusi zocken.
Oder kicken. Was ich kenne, ist zocken. Kicken, Pöhn.
Was ich kenne ist Poudern.
Echt?
Wenn man Skifahren geht, dann ist es Poudern.
Dann sagt man, hey, wollen wir Poudern gehen?
Aber mit P-O-W-D-E-R?
Ja, ja.
Oh, also ich habe noch nie nachgefragt.
Entschuldigung, wie buchstabieren Sie das eigentlich?
Entschuldigung, 12-jähriger Fred.
Kann ich das schriftlich haben?
Entschuldigung, ich würde das kurz in meine Archivare verlegen.
Wann fängt man an, ein Archiv anzulegen?
Habe ich mich gefragt und habe ich als auch eine Antwort gefunden. Und zwar jetzt. Ich fange jetzt ein Archiv an.
Aber haben wir nicht alle schon ein Archiv als Menschen des digitalen Zeitalters? Ich habe letztens eine Biografie von Freud gelesen, der einfach im Alter von 27 gesagt hat, ich bin 26, ich bin fast 27, er hat im Alter von 27 gesagt, nee, meine Gedanken sind schon so fucking gut, dass sie der Nachwelt erhalten bleiben müssen. Und er hat dafür gesorgt, dass all seine Briefwechsel, all seine Unterlagen, sein Tagebuch, alles Archiviert und aufgehoben wird. Mit 27, ich meine, der hat da schon viel erreicht, aber trotzdem mit 27 zu sagen, alles, was ich ab jetzt sage, ist Kulturerbe. Bis dahin nicht, aber ab jetzt schon. Ja, vor allem, was war der Moment, was ist denn Tag davor passiert? Gute Frage, er hat davor da viel vernichten lassen, so alles Bullshit und so, aber jetzt hat er gesagt, nee, ab jetzt geht's. Hat er einfach seinen Wikipedia-Eintrag löschen lassen oder was? Der hat sich Sachen ins Flammen geworfen und so. Das kann man auch nicht mehr. Du kannst sich dein Handy in Flammen werfen und hoffen, dass dann alle Bilder weg sind. Das ist ein interessanter Punkt. Der Mensch entscheidet nicht mehr selber, ob archiviert werden soll, sondern jeder wird automatisch archiviert werden. Firmen entscheiden, wer archiviert wird, wer nicht. Ich habe nämlich ein paar Sachen. Du nennst die Namen, das finde ich gut bei dir, dass du auch die Namen der Verbrecher nennst. Du, Google, ich nehme kein Blatt von dem Mund. Ho, ho, ho, ho, ho, mal gucken, wie lange es in einem Podcast noch gibt. Hoho, hoho, hoho, das Ding ist nämlich, du konntest irgendwann mal bei Google so verschiedene Richtlinien, da gibt es diese EU-Richtlinien, die man manchmal liest, wenn man Dinge googelt, die man nicht sieht, das wird dann irgendwie durch EU-Richtlinien verborgen geblieben.
Da kannst du einfach, konnte ich ein paar Artikel von mir im Nirvana verschwinden lassen.
Bei Google?
Sprich, ich würde dich in die Flammen schmeißen, ja.
Aha.
Ein paar Sachen gibt es da, jetzt nicht mehr von mir zu sehen. Diese unangenehme Anklagegeschichte. Ja, das ist interessant. Aber auch so Sachen wie Posthum veröffentlichen, kann man dann sagen, ich möchte bei Google nach meinem Tod, dass die wieder freigeschaltet werden? Oh. Weil das ist ja auch interessant, so Posthum-Sachen zu machen. Ey, mega, vor allem wenn man Tweets kann man ja mittlerweile auch schedulen. Und wie cool wäre das jetzt, wenn plötzlich so ein David Bowie-Tweet kommt. Wow, wow! Alle so so, ah! So an der Busseite stellen, so zwölf und die gleichzeit. Ah! Oh, ich dachte, er lebt noch. Oh, doch nur ein geschedulter Tweet. Und alle geben sich so recht, ja, war nur ein geschedulter Tweet. Stimmt. Okay, die alte Frau auch, ja, jetzt habe ich mich kurz gewundert. Jetzt haben wir recht, jetzt haben wir doch, Gott sei Dank haben wir doch recht. Er ist tot und er bleibt tot. Sehr gut. Aber es ist ja noch eine interessante Frage, dass wenn jemand stirbt, ein Künstler, ob man dann posthum seine Werke veröffentlichen kann, die er eigentlich nicht veröffentlicht haben wollte. Antwort, ja. Klar, viele machen Geld daraus. Da habe ich gesagt, gesagt ... Ist das verwerflich? Ich hab mal den Zeigefinger gehoben bei der Roger Cicero-Sache. Ich hab mal kurz in der Bahn gesagt, Leute, ganz kurz mal eben, hey, hey, mach die Musik aus. Hey! Und da hab ich gesagt, jetzt hören wir mal nur zu, diese Sache, dass da jetzt Werke veröffentlicht werden von Roger Cicero, finde ich nicht okay, weil er jetzt tot ist.
Doch, so gesammelte Sachen haben die da noch. Die Briefe, gesammelte Briefe. Ja, Steuererklärungen, Sachen, die er weg, die GEMA-Anmeldungen, sowas halt. Nein, weiß ich nicht mehr. Auf jeden Fall haben die dann nachher auch noch so ein paar Sachen veröffentlicht, genau wie bei Michael Jackson ja auch. und das ist nicht, was er noch so im Posteingang hatte, einfach so, was noch nicht weitergeleitet wurde, aber so war. Genau, was er noch im Demo, unfertig, auf gar keinen Fall auch nach meinem Tod nicht veröffentlichten Ordner hatte. Da waren noch spannende Sachen drin. Aber man muss ja tatsächlich ein bisschen aufpassen, ne, ich hab letztens mit ihm gesprochen. Bei allem, man muss bei allem aufpassen. Ne, tatsächlich nur bei dieser einen Sache, über die ich rede, wo die Person gesagt hat, man so im Scherz sagt, so ja, wenn du stirbst, dann xy. Das ist aber tatsächlich problematisch, weil sobald jemand stirbt, tritt so was in Kraft und man kann es dann nicht mehr zurücknehmen. Beispiel? Zum Beispiel, von wegen so, ah ja, ich will, dass meine Asche, dass ich verbrannt will, meine Asche soll in Brownie gebacken werden und dann sollst du den essen. So, und dann stell dir mal vor, duhst dann beim Kremateur und sagst so, sorry, kann ich kurz eine Sache noch haben, ganz, ganz tolle Rede, ich finde da bräuchte so eine tolle Rede, aber könnte ich die Asche haben und haben sie ein bisschen Mehl da, haben sie vielleicht so Schoko, sorry, Entschuldigung, ich setze mich gleich wieder hin, hat jemand Schoko, Sie brauchen den Sicherheitsdienst nicht rufen, Sie brauchen den nicht rufen. Entschuldigung, Zahn, Zahn, Kram, Zucker, sorry, sorry, ich sag, hey, hey, hey! Und so ist es dann einfach. Aber nur weil du einfach den Wunsch deiner geliebten Person erfüllen sollst. Wie gesagt, es ist ein großes Problem. Nimmt man dann den Elefanten-Grabstand oder nicht? Ja. Es ist wirklich ein großes Problem, weil Leute haben einfach so viel Macht mit dem, was sie dann sagen. Ja, vor allem, wenn es im Testament steht, dann hat die Person sich das überlegt und das ist gut und Notar hat das abgenommen. Aber wenn man das so nebenbei sagt. Es bräuchte so einen Ironienotar, den Irotar. Ja. Und der müsste entscheiden, Moment, das war ironisch gemeint, das war als Gag gemeint. Ja. Ich habe ja hier schon oft meine Anekdote zu Besten gegeben, mein Bit, dass wenn ich sterbe, sollt er nie wieder glücklich sein. Ihr alle sollt nicht ... Ich würd mich daran halten. Ich mein, ich werd sowieso nicht glücklich. Zu allem sollt ihr sagen, hätte er es so gewollt, nein. Hätte er gewollt, dass wir glücklich werden, nein. Hätte er gewollt, dass wir weitermachen, nein. Das sage ich hier oft immer. Und dann, finde ich sollte es euch zumindest gestattet sein, zu dem Eronotar zu gehen und zu fragen, wie haben wir das zu bewerten. Kann er so was sagen wie, es war im Bit eines Comedy-Podcasts, also wahrscheinlich wollte er, dass er wieder glücklich wäre, und er hat das genutzt, dieses geflügelte Prinzip, und dementsprechend würde er weitermachen. Aber ich weiß nicht, wie man da ... Ja, aber Ironie und Witz ist ein riesiges Problem, weil wenn du dir heute mal so einen Blogpost anschaust von keine Ahnung, irgendeinem Gesellschaftskritiker von Serdar Sumuncu oder so was und dann schreibt er da einen Text und natürlich macht er da viele Gags und ironisch und sagt dann sowas wie Lügenpresse, benutzt er als Begriff vielleicht, ich weiß nicht, was er schreibt, aber vielleicht benutzt er diesen Begriff ironisch, um sich über die AfD lustig zu machen und so. Aber all diese ganzen Konzepte gehen ja komplett verloren. Er liest den Text in 200 Jahren und das checkt kein Mensch mehr. Natürlich gibt es dann vielleicht ein paar Experten, die so Facebook-Experten, die sich auf Selders und Mundschuhe spezialisiert haben, die es vielleicht bereuen irgendwann, aber sich sagen, gut, ich musste einfach in der Vorschule, weil wir haben, unser Schulsystem ist ein bisschen beschissen geworden, in der Vorschule musste man schon sein Spezialgebiet wählen für sein ganzes Leben und ich habe mich für Sider-Sumunschel entschieden. Rückblickend doof, aber jetzt bin ich halt Experte, die kennen sich aus, aber alle anderen stehen mit grossen Fragen in Augen und münden dann vor dem Text und sagen, was soll das? Es gibt ja auch Leute, die dann noch zu Lebzeiten, also jetzt der Nussumunschel wäre dann in dem Beispiel schon tot, aber es gibt auch Leute, die sich zu Lebzeiten mit Leuten beschäftigen, mit Künstlern. Oder zum Beispiel die KHM, die Kunsthochschule für Medien in Köln, die hat da zum Beispiel von einem lebenden Künstler so ein Logo, so ein schwarzes Quadrat. Und irgendwann kam raus, uh, der Typ ist ein Antisemit. Aber das ist gar nicht schwarz. Moment, da ist noch eine Graustufe drin. Richtig, und dann gibt's nämlich das Original, haben die dann gefunden, das Originalbild dieses schwarzen Quadrats, haben die dann irgendwann mal umgedreht und dann war irgendwie ein fucking Hakenkreuz runter oder so. Wie umgedreht? Die haben das Bild umgedreht, das war ein Original. Ach so. So. Und das hat davor nie jemand mal umgedreht. Ich weiß nicht genau, ob die Geschichte so ging oder ob ich mich gerade ... Auf jeden Fall, oder haben das abgekratzt, genau, abgekratzt war es, glaube ich. Ich weiß nicht, warum das hat der Versteckter drunter, oder was? Auf jeden Fall war da ein fucking Hakenkreuz. Man kann ja so Röntgenstrahlen, so durchgucken vielleicht, haben wir das da gesehen. Auf jeden Fall hat man irgendwas gesehen, wo man dachte, fuck, und wo die Hochschule dachte, shit. Wir hatten die ganze Zeit einfach, auch die in ihrem Logo hatten, und da kann man alle Logos, alle Rechnungen wegkreuzen. Warum haben wir das so gedruckt? Wir haben uns auch was drunter gedruckt mit dem Hakenkreuz. Verdammt, doofe Idee. Aber der lebt noch, oder was? Ja. Und den kann man fragen, so die Frage, äh, was soll das? Ja, joke, just kidding! Ich konnte nicht wissen, dass sie den Krieg verlieren. Stellt euch vor, die hätten gewonnen, wäre das ein mega Ding gewesen, aber nein. Das ist in der Fällen das cool, wir sind ein Überraschungsei, ein NS-Überraschungsei. Was ist das denn? Aber ich finde, Tod und gerade Selbstmord ist ein Problem, vor allem ist mir jetzt aufgefallen, durch die ganze Linkin-Park-Nummer, der Sänger von Linkin-Park hat sich umgebracht, Chester Bennington, weil er Depressionen hatte. Weiß man das? Woher weiss man das? Hat er mal gesagt, in dem Bild. Ja, und nur weil er irgendwann sagt, er hat Depressionen und sich umbringt, heißt er nicht, dass es zusammenhängt. Kann er sein, gesagt, dass er Schulden hat. Gut, okay. Gut, ich meine, es ist ein Allerien, aber ich würde sagen, du hast es jetzt als Faktum präsentiert, das wir nicht haben. Sorry, wir haben auch eine gewisse journalistische Aufsicht. Deswegen, formuliere ich es um. Chester Benneken hatte Depressionen und Chester Benneken hat sich umgebracht. Alles klar. Und jetzt meine These. Es ist für Leute, die Depressionen haben und keine Weltstars sind, scheiße. Extrem scheiße. Weil überleg mal, du sagst, jemand, der Depression hat, und dem geht es unfassbar gut, der hat Denkmann, der hat unfassbar viel Geld, der hat unfassbar viele Fans, die ihm jeden Tag das Glück der Welt wünschen, der erlebt seinen Traum als Musiker, er macht die Musik, er kann sich als Künstler selbst verwirklichen, kann machen, was er will, weil er so viel Einfluss hat, aber bringt sich um, weil er Depressionen hat. Ist doch für Leute, die Depressionen haben, plus ein Scheißleben, echt mega uncool. Das stimmt. Eigentlich müssten die sich auch umbringen, weil er sagt ja eigentlich, wenn er es nicht hinkriegt. Und deswegen finde ich es ein verdammtes Arschloch. Weil was ist das denn für ein Zeichen? Was ist das denn für ein Zeichen von dem? Vielleicht sollten noch ein paar Lebende auch behaupten, sie hätten Depressionen, einfach um es auszugleichen. Genau. Dass jetzt einfach irgendwie, keine Ahnung, Michael Keaton vorkommt und sagt, Leute, Willy Brandt zum Beispiel sagt, hier, ich auch, einfach damit du die Harmonie wieder ausgleichst. So jemand, der ein tolles Leben hat, keine Ahnung, so eine Avery Levine, die guckt man sich gerne an, die hört man sich gerne an. Wo ist Avery Levine? Die hört man sich gerne an. Was macht Avery Levine? Keine Ahnung. Hat die jemals mit der Musik gemacht nach She was a skater boy, a sexy skater boy, da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da des 20.. Jahrhundert. Ja, das stimmt.
Eins war das. Ich kann mir auch vorstellen, dass vielleicht, wenn du depressiv bist und dir denkst, ja, wenn ich mal bei reich und berühmt bin, dann passt das alles schon so. Dann bist du reich und berühmt und merkst, nee, ist immer noch scheiße und dann bringst du dich um. Ach, du meinst, die haben mehr gesehen, die konnten tiefer in sich reinblicken in dem Sinne, dass sie quasi alle ihre Träume, die sie denken, die auf dieser Welt möglich sind, erschaffen. Es ist doch schlimmer, wenn du unglücklich bist und dir sollte es eigentlich gut gehen, als wenn du unglücklich bist und dir sollte es eigentlich auch unglücklich gehen, weil du bist halt irgendwie ein dummer Podcast-Hörer, der irgendwie keine Freunde hat und wenig Geld. Dann sagst du, ja, das passt schon so zusammen. Aber wenn du jetzt Weltstar bist und denkst, mir geht's nicht gut, dann sagst du, fuck. Du sagst, man will den Berg hochgehen und denkt, das wäre sein grösster Wunsch. Und es ist doch besser, noch ein bisschen Bergvorsicht zu haben, als um am Gipfel zu sein. Und am Gipfel steht der Galgen. Du sagst, man ist wie ein Maulwurf, der möglichst tief in die Erde will, da ist es doch besser, nicht am Erdkern zu sterben, sondern noch ein bisschen Erde vorsicht zu haben, wenn man graben kann. Nicht zitierfähig vielleicht, aber im Grunde vielleicht so was. Du sagst, man ist wie ein Friseur, der möglichst viele Kunden haben will, und da ist es ist doch besser, nicht alle Kunden bereits vergrault zu haben, als noch welche davor vor sich zu haben, denen man gegebenenfalls die Haare schneiden darf. Ja, sowas schon. Man kann es zusammenfassen. Vielleicht nicht unbedingt auf den Rücken meines Buches drucken, aber an sich schon. Willst du mal ein Buch schreiben? Ja. Aber ein Scherzbuch, ne? Ja. Was wäre die Widmung am Anfang? Die wäre schon ein Gag, glaube ich. Ich glaube, wenn ich ein Buch schreibe, dann unter falschem Namen. Weil einerseits habe ich keinen Bock auf diesen Fan-Hype irgendwie, jetzt nicht, dass ich unraublich viele Fans hätte, aber das ist ja doof so, weil keine Ahnung, du bist jetzt was als ich irgendwie ein berühmter Twitter-Typ, so du hast hunderttausend Follower, so dann schreibst du ein Buch und es verkauft sich dann 50.000 Mal und du sagst, wow, 50.000 Mal.
Aber dann denkst du dir, was kann ich denn mit der Zahl
anfangen? Also die Leute kennen
mich und deswegen haben sie das Buch gekauft. Du kriegst ja kein
Feedback von Büchern, da gibt es keine Kommentarspalt
oder keine Sternebewerbung.
Es gibt Lesungen, wo Leute anderen reinrufen.
Das gefällt mir, die Stelle mag ich nicht.
Lustig, gute Formulierung,
Syntax gut, Semantik
schwach. Gut, klar, auf solchen Lesungen war ich auch schon. Das stimmt, aber an sich, ich glaube, ich würde...
Du warst der eine Typ, der all diese Sachen gesagt hat. Ich glaube, ich würde tatsächlich unter dem falschen Namen Buch schreiben, ein Pseudonym.
Oh, jetzt kann es natürlich sein, weil das genau würdest du ja sagen, in zehn Jahren, wenn du unter dem falschen Namen bereits ein Buch veröffentlicht hättest, würdest du es ja genauso sagen.
Heißt, wir können uns nicht sicher sein, dass du nicht schon lange unter dem falschen Namen meinen Kampf veröffentlicht hast. Absolut, mein Kampf für Kinder. Absolut, nee. Mein Kämpfchen. Oh, gibt es einen zweiten Teil? Noch mehr Kampf? Mein Kampf zwei. Dein Kampf? Mein Kampf, dein Kampf? Unser Kampf. Das stimmt schon, ja. Unser Kampf, sei denn, du bist Jude und oder nicht Aria. Ja, eigentlich eine gute Idee, so wie bei der Bibel einfach zu sagen, ey, das war schon geil, lass uns noch einen zweiten Teil machen. Klar, weiter geht's. Wie die Mormonen, die sogar nur einen dritten Teil haben. Absolut. Obwohl, es ist ja die Frage, was dann der offizielle zweite Teil ist, ne? Empire Strikes Back. Ist es doch echt schon, also so Empire Strikes Back. Habe ich gerade gesagt, hat niemand gehört, weil du drüber geredet hast. Ich dachte, wir machen einfach nochmal. Aber wir schneiden heute nicht. Das ist die erste Folge des Podcasts, wo wir nicht schneiden. Ansonsten machen wir das eigentlich auch nicht, dass wir so unsere Gags konstruieren. Stimmt, die Botschaft kam falsch rüber, das stimmt. Aber es ist schon verrückt, in der Zeit gelebt zu haben, in der Religionen im Entstehen waren. Heute kann sich niemand vorstellen, dass die Bibel noch mal erweitert wird. War die mal im Entstehen? Also war die mal, oder hat man das gemerkt dann? Es gab doch zum Beispiel Mittelalter und so Päpste-Kongresse, wo man sich entschieden hat, welche Teile der Bibel jetzt offiziell sind und welche nicht. Ja, aber auch die haben ja nicht gesagt, an was wir glauben wir jetzt, sondern an was, die haben zumindest entschieden, diese und diese Parts sind es wert, weil das ... Genau. Mir gefällt die Noah-Geschichte. Die finde ich gut. Wer mag Noah? Das ist mit dem ... Wer mag Spider-Girl? Das mit dem Affen und der Giraffe, das lassen wir mal komplett raus. Verwirrendes Chapter. Timon und Pumba. Nicht, ernstlich nicht. Ich mochte es. Ich habe drei Stimmen, ich habe die grösste Mütze. Aber das ist aber heute in der Religion so. Wer hat entschieden, die grösste Mütze gewinnt. Ich wette, dieser Satz steht sogar in Latein natürlich besser. So Hutus, Maximus, Victorius. Und ich glaube, aber irgendwo wird das so stehen, dass der mit den meisten wie wer schreibt, der bleibt. Das stimmt, deswegen kann man die auch wiegen dann so gegenseitig. Aber es ist tatsächlich, heute ist ja unvorstellbar, dass man sagt, so Leute, Koran, lass noch einen zweiten Teil machen. Irgendwie noch so ein bisschen was mit Frauen. Meine weibliche Hauptfigurur, mal eine Protagonistin, mal so eine starke, selbstbestimmte Frau, irgendwie die dann irgendwie auch mal so, auch mal so nicht kämpferisch. Nee, warum denn nicht? Lass uns doch mal so. Die haben einfach so eine Identifikationsfigur für junge Muslimer, die irgendwie auch mal sagen so, hey, ich will's auch mal zu. Warum denn nicht mal irgendwie, keine Ahnung, oder was Geschlechtsneutreit? Die sollen mal schön ihre Haare verdecken. Die sollen mal schön in so grosse Tücher das legen, auch im Sommer.
Klar. irgendwie, keine Ahnung, oder was Geschlechtsneutral ist. Die sollen mal schön ihre Haare verdecken. Die sollen mal schön
in so große Tücher das legen.
Auch im Sommer. Auch im
Freibad. Absolut. Da will
ich gar nichts dran rütteln. Gut. Vielleicht so ein geschlechtsloses
Tier. Na gut, Schlange ist vielleicht.
Irgendwie so ein Esel. So ein lustiger Esel.
Der irgendwie so von Eddie Murphy könnte synchronisiert
werden. Und dann haben wir irgendwie so eine lustige Figur, die aber auch
mal sagt so, Frauen sind auch
ganz okay. Nicht gut, ganz okay. Okay. Okay. So geht's weiter. Unvorstellbar dieses alberne Szenario, unvorstellbar heute. Vor tausend Jahren war es noch so, ach komm, ey, diese Geschichte mit dem Typen, der Elektrizität erfindet. Aber vor allem sind die ja nicht wirklich übertragen, also ist ja nicht so, dass die immer Lehren haben. Also nicht alle Bibelstellen liefern irgendwie so ein gewisses Wertepaket mit. Manche sind auch einfach so ein bisschen seltsam, oder? Ich glaube, es ist ... Also diese Abraham-Nummer ist, also diese Abraham-Nummer, wo er töte deinen Sohn und dann nach drei Kapiteln sagt er, na, war nur ein Spaß, brauchst du nicht töten. Oder? Nee, der musste den ja nicht töten. Ich glaube, er hat ihn schon getötet und dann hat Gott gesagt, nee, hättest du nicht brauchen. Hättest du nicht machen. Sorry, ich war mega betrunken. So, ich ging im Stau, Alter. Ich war mega betrunken, als ich das letzte Mal angebetet habe, es tut mir mega leid. Sorry, du kannst ihn auch wiederbeleben. Shit. Ist ganz schlimm. Aber du hast doch Zauberkräfte, du bist doch allmächtig. Könntest du nicht die Zeit zurückführen wie Superman? Sorry, Verbindung, da kommt gerade so eine Wolke. Schiebt sich genau. Es war eine andere Zeit einfach. Ich habe mir gerade überlegt, ob es möglich ist, einen Text zu schreiben, der keine Botschaft hat. Wann hat, ich möchte da gleich darauf eingehen, wann hat Gott aufgehört zu sprechen? Danke. Mit Jesus. Genau, Gedanke beendet. Ja, kann man einen Text schreiben, der keine Botschaft hat? Was heißt Botschaft? Natürlich hat jeder Text einen Plot, etwas, das passiert, aber zu sagen, da kann man was draus ziehen. Also ist jeder Text interpretierbar, ist meine Frage. Dann möchte ich dich fragen, was ziehst du aus Pöntchen und Anton? Die Kraft der Freundschaft. Was ziehst du aus Timon und Pumpe? Die Kraft der Freundschaft. Was ziehst du aus Harry Potter und der Feuerkirche? Die Kraft der Freundschaft. So, du kannst mindestens immer die Kraft der Freundschaft aus. Aber lass uns mal interpretieren für mich mal bitte den folgenden Satz. Stefan hat Zeit. So, da drin steckt zum einen, er ist unwahrscheinlich, ist er langweilig, weil er hat Zeit. Wenn er nicht langweilig wäre, hätte er auch keine Zeit. Dann würde er Dinge machen, er hätte Pläne, er hat offensichtlich keine Pläne. Es schwingt mit, vielleicht sollte er was zu tun haben, vielleicht sollte man ihm was helfen, ihm was zu tun geben. Aber das ist jetzt nicht wirklich eine Botschaft. Man sollte ihm ein Projekt, es ist ein Hilfeschrei, es ist primär. Man sollte ihm die Selbstmord-Hotline-Nummer geben, einfach mal so, nur mal so einen Raum werfen, so ein nettes Gespräch, so heisst Stefan, wie geht's dir, 0800, 101, 101, 101, und dann einfach mal so ein bisschen. Das sind so ein T-Shirt. Warum trägt meine Familie so T-Shirts von der Selbstmord-Hotline?
Aber alle haben ...
Der Bruder hat die Null, der Onkel hat die Acht.
Und manchmal setzen sie sich falsch rum an den Tisch.
Falsche Butter.
Rufen sie aus, wo sie so eine Sex-Hotline anheben.
Die Mord-Hotline.
Haben Sie schon eine Idee, wie Sie sich umbringen?
Wir haben ein paar ...
Für tolle Ideen zum Selbstmord drücken Sie die zwei.
Wollen Sie es lieber mit einer scharfen Klinge, Axt, Messer, dann drücken Sie die eins. Boah, das ist nicht für Verkehr am Hof. Alle haben, ich weiß nicht, glaube ich nicht mehr gewunken, alle haben hier gerade Feierabend. Ich kann nie einschätzen, wie weit man von außen in ein Haus schauen kann. Weil manchmal bin ich im Haus und denke mir, Alter, wenn jetzt gerade jemand sieht, wie ich mit der rechten Hand im Erdnussbutterglas, mit der linken Hand versuche, irgendwie mein Regal einzuräumen und gleichzeitig mit dem Fuss noch versuche, die Katze zu verscheuchen, das sähe richtig albern aus. Aber dann denke ich mir, wie funktioniert Physik? Keine Ahnung, schon mal mein Gehirn sagt, Leute, ich bin raus, sorry. Dein Gehirn sagt, sorry, auf Wiedervorlage, bitte. Keine Ahnung. Dein Gehirn ist so ein Typ, der wegrennt. Was ist meine Steuernummer? Was ist meine Steuernummer? Emma, bitte nach ... Nur die ersten drei Ziffern! Ein Ticket nach Schweden, bitte. Sorry! Hier, bitteschön. Sorry, wann hat meine Mutter Geburtstag? Nur kurz eine ... Ach, check ihn nach Schweden in zwei Minuten. Sag's mir kurz, zeig die Hände, zeig die Hände! Nur den Monat, den Monat! Ach Gott, ach ... Ja, ich ruf zurück, Mama. Okay, tschüss! Versteh, was du meinst. Ich hab neulich auf einem ähnlichen Tweet nachgedacht. Weil wenn man masturbiert, macht man die Rolleranzug. Wirklich? Auf jeden Fall. Aber wenn du im Moment bist, leidenschaftlich, du bist drin, deine Hand sagt, ich will dich jetzt aber, Stefan,
ich will dein dickes Druck.
Ja, okay, ich weiß, äh, es ist tatsächlich so, ich bin sehr rational.
Auch dann? Auch beim Sex?
Nee, auch beim Selbstbefriedigung.
Von Sex will ich gerade noch nicht sprechen.
Ähm, von Sex kann ich auch nicht sprechen.
Ähm, ja, gut, oral, äh, Onanie, Sex. Das ist der Pachterminus. Weiß ich nicht. Ich überlege halt, wie man Sex definieren kann. Ja, eben. Vor allem, ich habe überlegt, ist Oralsex schon, ist das schon Geschlechtsverkehr? Ja. Ich würde sagen, nur Einbahnstrasse. Ich würde sagen, Sex kommt ja von Geschlecht und sexuelle Handlungen sind alle Handlungen, für die dein Geschlecht relevant ist. Ich gehe, dass du das ein, weil du sonst mit 28. erst mal Sex gehabt hättest. Nein, alles, womit sozusagen deine Genitalien, dein Geschlecht involviert sind, wo das Geschlecht relevant wird. Also wenn du jetzt sagst, habe ich mit einer Frau eine sexuelle Beziehung oder eine nichtsexuelle Beziehung, frag dich, ist es notwendig, dass sie eine Frau ist, wenn ich heterosexuell bin?
Wir gehen zusammen ins Kino, würde ich auch mit einem Mann können. Du klingst wie das, wir hatten noch so ein, da gab es so neue Lernmethoden, dann gab es so ein neues Spanischheft und dann gab es immer so eine CD, die wir einlegen mussten dazu. Und er hat gesagt, er hat die Zio Uno. Und dann hat die vorgelesen, und ich habe nicht verstanden, was sie gesagt hat, weil es spanisch war, aber genau so klang, fragt euch, fragt euch, war ein Geschlechtsteil von euch involviert. Du klingst exakt wie so ein Buch, was man aufschlägt, wo man so ausmalen kann, da gibt es so ein junger Mädchen, und dann will sie nur Pfeile erklären, was zu sehen ist. Ja, klar. Hattet ihr Sex? Fragt euch. Aufgabe eins. Aber du willst hier schön einen wegdengeln, die Hand ist in die Margarine gesteckt, Stefan, Tizze ist bereit und los geht's, aber erst mal Roller anzu. Auf gar keinen Fall, also ich hab, also Punkt um 18 Uhr bin ich zu Hause. Und dann wird erst mal schön gehobelt. Ja, 18.30, 18.27 mache ich die Roller anzu, 18.28 ist das Licht an, der Laptop ist hochgefahren und ich setze mich hin. Vorspiel. Und 18.30 geht es los. Dann 18.35 sage ich, okay, langsam wird es Zeit. Also gehen wir schon mal die Favoriten und die Lesezeichen durch. Und 18.40 ist es vorbei. Oh, 40? Von 35 bis 40? Nee, 35 ist 10 Minuten. Habe ich dir schon mal erzählt mit Robbie Williams? Exakt 10 Minuten. Bei Cripps? Habe ich, glaube ich, schon mal erzählt. Dadurch hast du nicht gekig darauf eingestiegen. Das klingt ein bisschen so, als wäre es ernst gemeint. Aber gut, wir lassen das mal so für sich beruhigen. Oh, nur 10 Minuten? Das war nicht die Person, die ich mir erwartet hätte. Ich dachte mir, wir gehen das jetzt weitergeckig durch. Und dann aber, okay, was ist denn mit Robbie Williams? Ich habe mal Robbie Williams' Cripps gesehen, und da hat er sein Schlafzimmer vorgestellt, hat er so das Kamerateam, und dann hat er da so eine Stoppuhr liegen auf seinem Nachttisch, auf der noch stand, ich glaube, es war irgendwas im Bereich von 1,18, 1,18, Und dann hält er das so in die Kamera und sagt, ja, mein Rekord von gestern Nacht. What? Ich habe damals schon als 13-jähriges Mädchen gedacht. What? Also, mir war gar nicht bewusst, was denn jetzt genau. Also, ich dachte, erst mal geht es um Sex oder Masturbation.
Ich glaube um Masturbation.
Aber warum so ein Rekord von gestern Nacht?
Weil das sagt man doch eher, wenn man...
Weißt du, mal gestern Nacht, ich kann mich doch nicht genau an Wortlaut erinnern.
Aber du kannst dich an die Zahl erinnern, oder was? 1,18?
Naja, das merke ich mir natürlich.
Als Referenz merke ich mir das natürlich, sofort zu sagen, okay, wo stehe ich?
Und dann war es schon merkwürdig. Also so ein Robbie Williams, der dann prahlt damit, wie schnell er masturbiert, ganz merkwürdig. Wie schnell oder wie langsam? War das eine Stunde oder ein Tag? Keine Aussage. Ein Tag, 18 Stunden. Man hätte wahrscheinlich nochmal drauf zoomen müssen, um genau zu gucken, war es Anus oder war es Horus? Ich masturbiere seit einem Jahr 18 Tagen. Das wäre schon nicht so schlecht. Aber was ist denn da genau gut? Ist denn gut, schnell zu sein? Ich glaube, dann wäre schnell gut. Es gibt ja auch so was, diese Kekswichsenpraxis, wo der, der als letztes kommt, dann den Keks essen muss. Von daher ist ja, je schneller man ist, desto besser in dem Spiel. Von daher ... Ah, das heißt, schwule Leute sind in dem Spiel richtig gut. Also die, die im Kekswichsen gewonnen haben, ihr wollt ihr doch erregt, was außenrum abgeht, These, eure homosexuellen Mitschüler waren besser im Kekswichsen als ihr. Ja, wobei wir hätten da jetzt nochmal klären müssen, inwiefern Erregung dem zusteuert oder absteuert. Also, ob du automatisch schneller bist, wenn du erregt bist, ich weiß nicht. Wir rechnen das auf. Ich glaube, uns fehlt auch einfach die Erfahrung. Geilheitskutzchen. Vielleicht sollten wir einfach mal zum anderen Thema. Ich glaube, da haben wir beide nicht so die mega gute Expertise. Ich finde eine Sache unfassbar lustig, wo ich seit Tagen dober lache, immer wenn ich bei Facebook online gehe. Ich weiß nicht, wie es dir geht, weil wir beide haben ja die Masterclass von Aaron Sorkin gemacht, dem großen Screenwriter. Und wir haben da mitgemacht und dann bist du ja in der Facebook-Gruppe. Bist du da auch drin? Ja, klar. Es ist bei mir die einzige Gruppe, wo richtig viel Traffic ist. Da sind so 1.800 Leute drin, schätze ich mal. Die ballern die ganze Zeit ihre Screenwriting-Books, ihre Screenplays da rein, irgendwelche Links zu spannenden Vorlesungen und sowas. Und lächerlicherweise
fangen die gerade alle an,
Preise zu gewinnen.
Echt? Ja, also die gewinnen sämtliche
Kurzfilmpreise, auch
renommierte, so Toronto Filmfestival
und so Scheiss, werden
alle nominiert als beste Newcomer
Screenplays in ihren
komischen Distrikts
in den USA. Und ich denke mir
die ganze Zeit, hat Aaron Sorkin
das einfach geknackt? Hat er einfach
Vielen Dank. Screenplays in ihren komischen Districts in den USA. Und ich denke mir die ganze Zeit,
hat Aaron Sorkin das einfach geknackt? Hat er einfach
das Rätsel gelöst? Kann schon sein.
Hat er einfach gesagt? Aber warum
bist dann du kein
Buchcommerstar? Ich habe ja kein Drehbuch geschrieben,
das eingereicht. Ach so, du hast keine Ambitionen.
Außerdem bin ich ein Grimm-Preis-Bringer-Autor
bei guter Arbeit, okay.
Aber ich finde es so lustig, die Vorstellung, dass er einfach so ein paar, es war nicht mehr richtig konkret. Er hat gesagt, wie schreibt man Dialog, er hat gesagt, schreibt es einfach wie Musik. Und dann die Vorstellung, dass alle so, ah, und dann aufschreiben, so ein paar Sätze und dann zack, einfach alle gewinnen. Ich frage mich, wenn der Erste aus dieser Gruppe, vor allem erstmal, wenn ich was gewinnen würde, würde ich auch nicht da hinten reinschreiben, oh, geil, dank der Aaron-Sawking-Masterclass habe ich den deutschen Grimmelpreis gewonnen, würde ich niemals machen. Du würdest das doch nicht dem die Credits geben dafür. Und ich frage mich auch, ob diese Leute dann einfach, wenn die irgendwann mal einen Oscar gewinnen, auch in die Gruppe schreiben, wow, die Masterclass hat mir einen Oscar ermöglicht, geil. Auf der anderen Seite würde ich schon in jedem Film, den ich ab jetzt schreibe, am Ende schreiben, Special Thanks to Aaron Sorkin, einfach nur damit Aaron Sorkin in den Credits von meinem Film steht, scheißegal, was damit ist. Auch wenn er mit deinem schwachsinnigen Film nichts zu tun haben will. Kann man einfach Leuten danken? Klar, du kannst allen danken. Aber du kannst nicht einfach sagen, Special Thanks Quentin Tarantino, das muss er doch absiegen. Du kannst ja nicht einfach seinen Namen in deinen Credits... Das ist ja bei IMDB auch so. Du kriegst ja bei IMDB auch einen Thanks-Eintrag, einen Thanks Quentin Tarantino, das musst du ja doch absiegen. Du kannst ja nicht einfach seinen Namen in deines Kredits beschreiben. Das ist ja bei IMDb auch so. Du kriegst ja bei IMDb auch einen Thanks-Eintrag, einen Thanks-Credit. Also Leute, die gedankt wird, die kriegen dann eine IMDb-Seite unter anderem, wo dann, ähm, wo die einen Thanks-Credit bekommen haben, ja. Na, aber da kannst du ja doch nicht einfach jeden nehmen, da gibt's bestimmt Regeln. Ja, vor allem, siehst du dann, dein Cast und Crew sind einfach die, die gedankt, denen genannt wurde, sind wesentlich famer als denen, die mitgespielt haben und so.
Ja.
Das ist schon lustig. Das heißt, ich kann mir auch selbst danken und dann ist das auf meiner IMDb-Seite auch. Ja. Geil. Das ist nicht schlecht, das mache ich. Richtig gut, ne? Das finde ich so lustig einfach. Die Vorstellung, dass Aaron Sorkin einfach raus hat, wie man Drehbücher schreibt. Ja, ich erwarte jetzt auch auf die ganzen Leute, die die Masterclass Stage Performance von Usher gemacht haben, dass sie jetzt einfach ganz
viele neue Talente aus dem Boden
spriegen. Stimmt, und vor allem
ist es nicht so, dass Serena Williams Tennis lehrt.
Ja, genau. Wie läuft das eigentlich?
Du kannst ja nicht zu Hause in deinem Wohnzimmer
lernen, wie man Drehbücher schreibt, aber du kannst
nicht lernen, Tennis zu spielen. Es gibt die Seite
Masterclass, wo man sich von berühmten Leuten beibringen
kann, wie jeweils ihr Handwerk funktioniert.
Für 90 Dollar kann man das bezahlen, dann kriegt man so 20, 30 Videos und kann sich die angucken und kann es dann lernen, kriegt auch kleine Aufgaben und so.
Da gibt es jetzt ein paar mittlerweile, wie gesagt Aaron Sorkin Screenwriting, es gibt auch für Kochen und Schach gibt es zum Beispiel auch und Hans Zimmer macht auch Musik, Werner Herzog macht Filme und sowas in der Richtung.
Und es sind eigentlich künstlerische Sachen.
Hans Zimmer nicht, ne?
Doch, Hans Zimmer hat auch.
Achso, doch.
Ach cool.
Mach ich auf jeden Fall auch noch.
Auf jeden Fall, klar.
Und ... Er macht auch Musik, Werner Herzog macht Filme und so was in der Richtung. Und es sind eigentlich künstlerische Sachen. Hat Zimmer nicht, ne? Doch, hat Zimmer auch. Achso, doch. Ach cool. Mag ich auf jeden Fall auch noch. Auf jeden Fall, klar. Und das ist halt cool, weil das alles künstlerische Berufe sind. Die kann man, man kann die nicht lernen, aber man guckt den Leuten zumindest gerne zu. Man kann sich was sagen lassen. Genau, man will sich sagen lassen, wie andere Leute das machen. Und es ist auch beruhigend zu hören, dass in Aaron, ja, es ist, eigentlich ist es sehr beunruhigend, dass auch in Aaron Sorkin nicht Dialog aus dem Handgelenk schreibt, sondern wochenlang progressiert und dem ist nicht gut dabei. Aber es ist trotzdem cool zu hören, was deren Praktiken sind und einfach diese Gruppe, wo alle plötzlich wahnsinnig erfolgreich sind. Wenn Serena Williams plötzlich sagt, einmal so, der ist dann so Tennisranglisten Erste, sagt dann auch so, ja, vielen Dank an die Masterclass von Serena Williams. Oder die machen einfach so. Leute, einfach immer abwechselnd Rückhand, Vorhand, Rückhand, Vorhand und plötzlich einfach alle Wimbledon machen da hier ein Ding, einfach komplett übernehmen einfach alles. So viele gute Tennisspieler. Es gibt vielleicht auch, vielleicht gibt es auch schon so viele gute Tennisspieler. Ich glaube, welche Sportart hat die meisten Spieler? Oh, weißt du, was mich interessiert? Wahrscheinlich so amerikanisches Football. Na, aber Fußball ist doch der grösste Sport. Kann sein, ja. International. Aber Frage, welche Sportart hat die besten Menschen, die nicht mehr, die nicht weit voneinander entfernt sind? Also, was ist, was hat die geringsten Abstände? Aha. Also, muss man halt umrechnen, weil so die 100-Meter-Sprinter, die liegen halt nur Nanosekunden auseinander. Aber das ist ja umgerechnet, vielleicht können die dann ... Schwer zu sagen, nicht? Stehen die dann einmal weniger im Abseits. Ja, das ist schwer zu rechnen, ja. Ja, es ist wirklich schwer zu rechnen. Aber welcher Sport hat die schlechtesten Sportler? Baseball. Gar ohne zu zögern.
Ich wollte hier mal mein Gehirn benutzen.
Es ist Baseball.
Das ist lächerlich.
Wir haben beim zweiten Mal Baseball gucken herausgefunden.
Ich weiß nicht, wie es dir ging,
aber mir hat es nicht mehr so viel Spaß gemacht wie beim ersten Mal. Ich verstehe mehr und mir macht es immer mehr Spaß.
Es ist viel Wissen haben wir wieder verloren.
Wir haben ein paar Indings gebraucht.
Acht, um reinzukommen wieder. Versteht niemand? Gib neun. Der sagt das doch vor dem Gag. Ich habe auch überlegt, ich habe neulich ein Gag bei Twitter rausgekommen, wo ich dachte, ich male einfach danach den Gag nochmal auf, für Leute, die es nicht verstanden haben. Weil ich kriege mittlerweile viele I don't get it. Ja? Ja, ich weiß nicht, ich entferne mich von den Leuten, die mich
lesen. Ja, aber
dann haben wir
herausgefunden zum Beispiel, dass es eigentlich
auf die Würfe ankommt.
Also je mehr du in die Mitte wirfst,
desto besser ist es
für dein Team, also du darfst sie nicht
verwerfen, darfst aber auch nicht zu schwach werfen,
sonst können andere schlagen. Und da entscheidet sich das,
in diesem kleinen Moment. Das haben Leute, glaube ich, herausgefunden und trainieren nur das. Deswegen haben die auch alle ihre Schultern kaputt und so und können massiv schnell werfen. Einfach acht Stunden am Tag. Genau. Und andererseits sind die beim Laufen extrem schlecht. Die sprinten nicht gut, obwohl das 50 Prozent des Sports ist Laufen. Ja, aber guck mal, das ist auch so, wenn du Koch bist, was lernst du dann? In der Küche schnell von links nach rechts laufen oder kochen, natürlich kochen. Klar, als Koch läufst du natürlich auch von der Pfanne zur Fritteuse, vom Backofen zur Pfanne, so hin und her, aber das würdest du nie, gut, kochen trainierst du jetzt wahrscheinlich auch nicht so wie in Sport, aber du trainierst jetzt nicht das Hin- und Herlaufen. Oder Start-Hochsprung, was trainierst du mehr? Das Laufen auf den Sprung oder dann von der Matte zur Startlinie? Aber das gibt doch keine Punkte. Okay Leute, wir trainieren heute mal nur von der Matte aufstehen, sich abklopfen, Danke sagen und nochmal an die Startlinie. Nee, mach da. Es mag lustig klingen, aber es macht keinen Sinn, okay? Weil das ist genauso, als würde man beim Baseballtraining, wie man in die Kabine geht nach dem Spiel. Wäre ein lustiger Sketch. Will ich mir anschauen, will ich doppelt lachen. Wenn ihr darüber gelacht habt gerade, dann habt ihr nicht verdient, Podcast-Urführer zu sein. Weil dann müsst ihr noch mal von vorne anfangen, von der ersten Folge. Du musst auch jetzt nicht so drauf rumreiten, dass niemand drüber gelacht hat, okay? Das war, ich glaube, es haben Leute drüber gelacht, das macht mich fuchsig, weil es keinen Sinn ergeben hat. Okay, dann fahr fort mit deiner Erklärung, warum Baseball kein guter Sport ist. Ist ein guter Sport. Ich glaube, Stab Hochspunk tatsächlich hat ein Freund von mir auf dem Schulweg, ich weiß nicht, ob du dich, können wir gleich über das Konzept Schulwege noch mal reden, auf dem Schulweg einfach so gesagt so, ja, mein Opa war ja Stabhochsprung-Weltmeister. Und dann? Wirklich Weltmeister? Ja, damals gab es aber auch nur so 20 Stabhochspringer. Okay, gut. Ich glaube, mein Bus kommt gleich einfach so, that's it, das ist die Story. Kein Stolz auf seinen Opa. Es hätte mich aber auch nicht gewundert, wenn keine Rückfrage gekommen wäre. Wenn er so ein Satz ist, den Mama sagt, wie, ich hab heute meine Hausaufgaben gemacht. Und dann reagiert niemand darauf, so, mein Opa war Stabhochsprung-Beltmeister. Was macht ihr heute Abend noch so?
Hat noch jemand was zu? Ja, das stimmt. Aber ey, Schulweg, du hast ja heute unvorstellbar. Du gehst zur Arbeit und dann bist du instant für dich selbst. Aber damals gab es ja noch diese Limbozone, wo du dann auch noch mit einigen Leuten nach Hause laufen musst, die du vielleicht auch gar nicht so gern magst. Weil die bei dir wohnen leider. Aber Das ist dann auch so unangenehm und dann läuft man manchmal auch hinter denen und dann kann man nicht so schnell laufen und dann nimmt man den Umweg, ganz unangenehm. Und dann teilweise gab es bei uns, also ich mag alle meine Freunde, die waren alle super, aber die warten dann auch irgendwie auf einen davor, dann gab es immer Treffpunkt Müllhäuschen und dann haben wir dann alle gewartet und dann war auch so, gehen wir jetzt los oder kommt der noch, ist der krank, weil heute ist, sonst kommen wir nicht rechtzeitig und jetzt müssen wir diskutieren und dann, ah, da hinten kommt er, schnell, beeil dich, dann kommen wir zu spät, dieses ganze Gedönsel. Herr Will, Sie haben in Ihrer Biografie Treffpunkt Müllhäuschen haben Sie vor allem die 18 von 20 Kapitel darauf, ich würde sagen, verschwendet, über Ihren Schulweg zu sprechen. Liegen da so ein paar Probleme, die Sie nicht ganz verarbeitet haben zugrunde? Es ist ein Buch über die Kraft der Freundschaft. Das ist meine Botschaft, das möchte ich damit klar aussagen. Das habe ich auch auf der ersten Seite direkt geschrieben. Mehrere Male geschrieben. Ich habe es ein paar Mal angesprochen, einfach damit da die Interpretation, damit sich da die Archivare in ein paar Jahren nicht verhuddeln. Das wäre für mich nichts, das möchte ich vermeiden. Was sollen die Archivare sich nicht? Die möchten sich bitte nicht verhuddeln, das habe ich auch tatsächlich auf den letzten paar Seiten geschrieben. Ich richte das an meine Archivare aus, dass sie nicht verhuddeln sollen. Ansonsten war es halt so, ja, Fabi kam immer zu spät, und das ist halt einfach nervig. Das hat wirklich drei Kapitel eingenommen, Fabi kam zu spät, eins, zwei, und Fabi kam irgendwann nicht mehr zu spät, weil es dann ja die Krebskrankheit gab. Richtig, richtig, und dann gab es immer den einen, der nicht Warhammer gespielt hat, und dann haben die anderen sich über Warhammer unterhalten und er immer so, ich mag Hasen und so und so Bullshit und so. Deswegen, ey Rudi, du bist echt ein dummer Penner und dass wir jemals mit dir einmal und das kannst du auch deiner Mutter sagen, Und ich bin froh, ihn nicht mehr zu kennen, von daher ...
Ja, vielen Dank für das Interview. Gerne.
Hast du alleine ...
Songwunsch?
Hast du alleine ... bist du alleine zur Schule gegangen?
Äh, nee.
Bus, Bus?
Buskind, klassisches Buskind.
Buki!
Es gab, und das habe ich bis heute nicht verstanden, den C22.
So, Carmen, stell dich Kamen vor eine,
sagen wir mal,
der Vereinfachung,
eine kreisrunde Stadt.
Im Südzipfel ich, der kleine Stefan.
So, jetzt gab es den C24,
den C23, und ich fahre den C22,
klar, der Bus aus Südkamen.
Jetzt kommt der aus der Innenstadt gefahren und fährt nach Südkamen und dann wieder in die Innenstadt rein.
Der fährt an meiner Busseite-Stelle vorbei,
ein Alten- und Behindertenzentrum,
fährt dann
Vielen Dank. er aus der Innenstadt gefahren und fährt nach Südkamen und dann wieder in die Innenstadt rein. Der fährt an meiner Bushaltestelle vorbei, ein Alten- und Behindertenzentrum, fährt dann weiter nach Südkamen rein, kommt dann wieder, fährt wieder zu mir in die Bushaltestation, wie random ist das denn und fährt dann wieder in die Innenstadt. Heißt, alle Haltestellen haben normale Zeiten, außer diese Station. Manchmal fährt er da rein, fährt dann die Runde in ganz Südsüd kam, fährt dann wieder zu mir und fährt dann in die Schule. Hat bei mir mein Leben lang zu massiven Verwirrung geführt, weil manchmal kam ich zu spät, war aber kein Problem, weil der Bus kam nochmal. Manchmal kam der Bus nicht nochmal und das hat mein Leben lang zu diesem Moment geführt, dass ich entweder kam ich möglich zur Schule oder nicht. nicht. Das waren die beiden Möglichkeiten, so je nachdem, ob der Busfahrer gerade nochmal da hält oder nochmal nicht da hält. Das war ein bescheuertes Konzept. Die Zeiten stimmten auch alle nicht, weil die Bushaltestelle hat nicht immer gerechnet, dass der Bus nochmal reinfährt. Das ist ja abgefahren. Aber ich habe gerade mir gedacht, dass ich mir noch nie Gedanken darüber gemacht habe, wo die Busse überhaupt herkommen. Ich dachte einfach, die sind da und fahren nicht zur Schule. Die fahren Kreise. Die fahren klassische Kreisprinzip. Aber ich glaube, weil das halt so eine Behindertenwerkstatt, ein Altersheim war. Ah, Demenz, ne? Haben die das, kam der Bus halt, der Bus kommt die ganze Zeit. Wenn die vergessen, dass der Bus kommt, kommt er nochmal. Weiß ich nicht, ob das Sinn gemacht hat. Ich möchte nicht drüber nachdenken. Aber ich glaube, deswegen sind die aus Kulanz dann auch mal dahingefahren, weil die den alten Leuten nicht zugetraut haben, den Plan zu lesen. Keine Ahnung. Ich habe es wieder nicht verstanden. Krass. Naja, aber das war mein Schulweg. Und ich habe ein traumatisches Erlebnis, wo ich beim Schwarzfahren erwischt wurde. Und da habe ich geweint. Vorm ganzen Bus habe ich geweint, weil er hat mir, und ich bin ein ehrlicher Mensch, und er hat mir vorgeworfen, ich wäre, ich habe ein Viererticket gehabt und ich habe das nicht abgestempelt. Alleine. Warum hattest du vier Fahrten? Ich dachte, vier Personen, du fährst immer mit vier Personen. Für meine Freunde! Mit meinem imaginären Freund. Naja, und dann kam es halt dazu, dass er mir vorgeworfen hat, dass du hast noch keinen Stempel darauf. Keinen von den vieren. Wahrscheinlich bist du schon den ganzen Monat lang schwarz gefahren. Und ich fand das so gemein, einfach diese Unterstellung, dass ich einfach angefangen musste zu weinen. Oh nein. Hattest du deinen Helm auf? Ja, zum Glück, natürlich. Konnte ja nichts passieren. Hattest du deinen Tränenfänger auf? Ja, und die Zahnspange im Mund. Gut, dann will ich nicht verschwenden, die Tränen. Dann will ich nicht verlieren. Und an dem Bügel hängt so ein Schlüsselbund und so ein Portemonnaie, so ein Heliumluftballon, damit deine Mutter immer weiss, wo du bist. Deine Mutter kann über die ganze Stadt Carmen schauen und sieht an dem 60 Meter langen Schnurf an deinem Heliumluftballon. An dem orangen Heliumluftballon kann deine Mutter immer sehen, ah, da ist der Stefan über der ganze Stadt. Aber ich hatte auch so getarnt als Propellermütze so eine Drohne, dass sie, wenn sie dachte, was macht der denn gerade, dass sie mich einfach fernsteuern nach Hause fliegen konnte. Ey, das ist doch die Zukunft der Drohnen, Eltern, die ihre Kinder in Fährsteuern.
Einfach wuuuuh.
Wo ist er, wo, ich sehe ihn nicht mehr.
Und dann einfach ein Hebel hoch, und man sieht so Kind aufsteigen.
Einfach so in zwei Blöcken entfernen.
Mitten im Gespräch, ja, ich finde die neue Staffel,
Yugi, oh, ist ja wirklich wuuuuh, wird hochgerissen.
Man spielt noch grad Beyblades und so.
Naja, und dann in der letzten Folge hat Yugi einfach weg, lässt alles fein. Weil Drohnen sind doch nicht mehr so schwer. Aber Apost und so, Paketlieferungen, weil sich alle aufregen von wegen, Hermes ist so scheiße und alles ist so scheiße und alle, die er... Schwer hat sich über Hermes aufregen. Malte, und die sind alle so scheiße so und von wegen, deswegen glaube ich ja, das wird ja bald einfach Drohnen sein, dass sie wirklich das Drohnen
zu dir nach Hause blopp vor dich hinlegen
und dann einfach abfliegen und das ist einfach
genial, so muss es sein. In Hamburg
habe ich ja diesen Fahnenroboter gesehen, wo ich mir denke,
warum überhaupt diese Fahnenroboter, wenn es einfach
nicht mit Drohnen besser geht? Ja, stimmt.
Und dann stürmt's und dann fliegen die
Pakete alle durch die Gegend, das geht ja nicht.
Und du schlägst die ganze Zeit mit offenen Armen.
Mit so einem grossen Handschuh, den du von Amazon bekommen hast. Wo? Komm, meine Gläser. Ich kaufe nie wieder Gläser bei Amazon Drone. Oh, Amazon Drone, finde ich gut. Amadrone. Amadrone und dem Paket kommt noch schneller. Ich finde, aber muss es da wirklich mehr Innovation geben? Ey, ich kippe bei Amazon was ein und dann kommt es am nächsten Tag und man denkt sich so, ja, das war schnell genug. Das ist eine der Dinge, die sind, ich finde, der ist der Service von sehr gut. Man will sich auch aufregen immer so gern, aber es ist sehr gut. Ich habe mich leider nicht mehr über Lieferzeiten von Paketen aufgeregt. Das hat sich schon ... Ja, ja. Überleg mal, als du im Alter von zwölf, dreizehn, vierzehn, wo ich unfassbar gerne angefangen habe, das Prinzip bestellen und Pakete bekommen entdeckt habe, da gab es kaum irgendwann mal so Sendungsverfolgung, fing dann irgendwann mal an. Ja, ja. Und so was. Und man hat wochenlang darauf gewartet, einfach auch Pakete. Mittlerweile kommen die einen am Tag. Kommt ja darauf an, ne. Gerade so Bücherversendungen sind wahnsinnig schnell am nächsten Tag da und dann musst du die auch noch lesen und so, das ist nervig. Aber zum Beispiel so aus Japan oder so, ich habe mir letztens ein neues Musiknutzung gekauft. Hey, wenn ihr denkt, Stefan kann Fehlkäufe tätigen, nope, Fehlkauf, Florentin kann auch was. Geil. Und ich habe mir ein Automaton gekauft. Oh, ich liebe die Dinger, die sind das Lustigste der Welt. Und die sieht aus wie eine große Note, also unten so ein Ball und dann so ein Stiel dran. Das habe ich noch nicht verstanden. Das wäre einfach... Doch, ne, es sieht aus, unten ist ein grosser Ball und dann ein Stiel dran. Aber haben die das Instrument nach der Form Note gebaut? Ja, das hat ja oben auch so ein Fähnchen. Ja, aber haben die ein Instrument gebaut und gesagt, oh, das sieht aus wie eine Note. Wir machen eine Note draus. Was war zuerst da, die Note oder das Instrument, die Form oder das Instrument? Man kann es ja auch seitlich machen. Also unten hast du so einen grossen Ball, der so aussieht wie ein Smile. Und dann kannst du so auf die Wangen draufdrücken und dann öffnet er den Mund und dann macht er ein Geräusch. Und auf dem Stiel legst du deinen Finger wie auf einer Geige, wie hoch oder tief der Ton sein soll. Und damit spielst du das Ding dann. Was kannst du daraus spielen? Das ist elektronisch. Keine Ahnung. Aber ich würde es gerne so gut beherrschen, dass ich jede Melodie damit spielen kann, die ich kenne.
Muss mal gucken, muss mal trainieren.
Aber dann ... Das mache ich dann zum Live-Podcast.
Das kommt mich dann raus.
Weisst du, was wir beim Live-Podcast machen?
Ein 80-köpfiges Onomatoton-Orchester.
Wenn ihr euch fragt, wo gehen meine Patron-Geller hin?
Jeden Monat schwemm ich da 40 Dollar in den Jordan. Nope, die kommen bei uns schon an und die werden investiert in ein riesengroßes Orchester für das Live-Event, die dann einfach noch mal, bevor Disney das Haus stürmt, das Intro anstimmen werden. Kein Scheiß, jetzt gerade wird uns in diesem Moment eine neue Titelmelodie komponiert.
Sollen wir das sagen? Ah, das dauert doch noch Monate. Nein, jetzt gerade wird eine neue Titelmelodie komponiert. Und ich weiß nicht, ob es schon auf dem Weg nach Babelsberg ist, aber das Filmorchester Babelsberg spielt die ganze Titelmelodie ein. Aber wenn wir das jetzt schon sagen, die Erwartungen sind so hoch. In der ganzen Fünf-Minuten-Version ein 90-köpfiges Orchester unter der Leitung von Daniel Barenboim in München spielen die Podcast-Uvo-Suite ein.
Und ich sag euch eins, das war nicht billig. Das war echt nicht billig, also wirklich nicht billig.
Aber wir haben auch ein bisschen was aus der eigenen Tasche gezahlt.
Aber das muss man auch mal machen, weil dann, wenn man so ein Intro mal hat, dann läuft das auch die nächsten Jahrzehnte. Und dann hat man es. Ja, vielen Dank an die Spendengelder. Dankeschön. Jetzt komm, jetzt lass uns mal auf ganz kurz das heiße Eisen ansprechen. Was ist denn jetzt mit einem Boosted Board? Du hast es bekommen, aber ich habe dich heute noch nicht über den Hoflitzen sehen. Was ist da los? Das Ding ist, es ist sehr schnell. Ich habe gestern in der Wohnung so einen leichten Schrecken bekommen, weil ich dachte, ich stelle mich mal drauf, mache mal die Fernbedienung an und dann fahre ich mal ein bisschen vor und zurück in der Wohnung. Keine gute Idee. Es ist unfassbar schnell, die Beschleunigung ist rasant, es ist unfassbar verboten in Deutschland, war das auch abgesehen. Und deswegen traue ich mich noch nicht so richtig, das auszuprobieren in Köln, weil hier keine großen Park, hier gibt es keine großen Freiflächen, wo wenig Leute sind. Aber was meinst du mit Fernbedienung, wie funktioniert das?
Du hast eine Fernbedienung in der Hand, eine kleine Fernbedienung,
Bluetooth ist, wie so ein kleiner,
kennst du,
so Karrierabahndinger, du hast so ein kleines
Rad oben und da kannst du Beschleunigung und Bremsen mit.
Dann zeigt es den Akkustand an
und es hat einen Anknopf.
Moment, es fehlt aber nicht, das heißt, wenn du
nichts mehr tust, dann hält dir die Geschwindigkeit oder
wird er dann automatisch langsamer. Genau, du hast ein Rad, da hat es einen Widerstand. Du musst nach oben, kannst ein Zentimeter nach oben und ein Zentimeter nach unten.
Das heißt, wenn du aus Versehen vom Board runter springst, fährst du weiter. Ach so, dann kannst du es ja anhalten.
Genau.
Aber wenn du die Fernsteuerung verlierst, dann bist du auf Gedai und Verderb den Rest des Lebens aus diesem Ding.
Nicht mehr muss das passieren. Es kann auch sogar passieren, dass die Verbindung abbricht einfach, weil gerade so,
weil kennt man ja, wir haben ja Bluetooth-Kopfhörer,
die verlieren auch manchmal einfach die Verbindung.
Wenn das mit dem Bootsobord passiert,
dann bin ich mein Leben lang auf den Kölner Ring,
fahre ich einfach so in einem grossen Kreis und
Hilfe!
Und Leute warten immer so alle viertel Stunde,
stehen sie an einem Starbucks,
an einem Kölner Ring und sehen mich vorbeifahren. Und so, uuuuh! Alter, am Wochenende war ich hier in Köln und ich habe so ein bisschen Sightseeing gemacht. Ich habe ein bisschen durch Köln gelaufen und habe ein paar Leute die Köln gezeigt. Und dann bin ich an der Seilbahn vorgekommen, diese Kölner Seilbahn. Es gibt ja diese eine Seilbahn, die über den Rhein fährt, an der Zoobrücke. Und dann haben wir noch überlegt vorher, wollen wir das mal machen? Ich war noch nie in dieser Seilbahn, in Köln gibt es einfach eine Seilbahn. Wie cool ist das denn, um reinzufahren? Wir haben uns dagegen entschieden. Gehen dann da vorbei, genau in diesem Moment sehe ich plötzlich so eine Gondel, fährt und sich so ein bisschen verkeilt und schräg hängen bleibt, mit einem Kind drin, mit dem Sendung mit dem Mauslogo obendrauf, hat sich herausgestellt, ist die fast einfach verunglückt, diese Seilbahn, überall kam Feuerwehr an, die haben alles abgesperrt, überall kam Feuerwehr, Höhenrettung und so, und dann haben die 65 Menschen, mussten die aus der Seilbahn befreien, und dann bin ich danach, bin ich dann auch durch Köln gelaufen, den ganzen Tag durch Köln gelaufen, so sechs, sieben Stunden, bin dann wieder vorbeigekommen und die waren immer noch am Retten. Alter. Heißt, die hatten einen furchtbaren Scheißtag in dieser Seilbahn, diese Leute. Oh, das ist ja aufregend. Also nicht auf, da sechs Stunden lang nicht mehr. Ja, vor allem manche Leute, und das ist mir eigentlich, ich dachte nur, okay, diese eine Gondel, die fast runtergefallen wäre, die mussten die retten. Nein, die mussten ja alle anderen Gondeln auch retten, auch die über dem Rhein und so. Ich fahre dann mit dem Schiff dahin oder was? Ja, da sind die mit dem Schiff, da kam so ein Feuerwehrwagen auf so einem Schiff und da hat der Leiter ausgefallen. Alter, und du siehst, die haben noch zehn vor dir und die so, können wir? Können wir zuerst? Können wir zuerst? Sorry, wir müssen raus. Sorry, unser Ofen ist an. Ihr? Wie nervig. Mega nervig.. Aber stand da nicht in der Zeitung sogar irgendein Heldenpassant, der das Kind gerettet hat oder so? Ich glaube, es war ein Feuerwehrmann, tatsächlich. Er hat sich herausgestellt, war doch ein Feuerwehrmann. Der Hut und die Jacke, hättest du daran erinnern können. Naja, und dann hat er einfach seinen Job gemacht, ein Kind gerettet, da standen Leute und haben geklatscht. Toll. Unten haben standen die und haben geklatscht. Toll! Ich find's toll. Man kann auch mal die öffentlichen Kräfte unterstützen. Da stand Schaulustige, und ich finde das Wort immer so lustig, Schaulustige haben geklatscht, weil ich finde, das klingt, als ob die so eine kleine Party veranstalten. Als ob so Gaukler Leute bespaßen und dann die die ganze Zeit dann klatschen und so. Schaulustige. Das machen die auch nicht aus Spaß. Zwang, das ist ja menschliche Psyche. Wenn was passiert, musst du hinschauen. Auch wenn es grauenvoll ist, auch wenn du es überhaupt nicht lustig findest, musst du hinschauen. Ich habe nur noch die Frau gesehen von dieser Seilbahnbesitzerin, die dann wütend rausgegangen ist und dann dieses Geschlossen-Schild umgedreht hat. Und überall Feuerwehr. Und überall Blaulicht. Da hat sie die einfach so genervt mit so einer langen Stahlstange, so dagegen gerammt, so komm jetzt, komm jetzt, stell dich zur Hand doch. Ich mach den Stecker raus und wieder an, okay, haltet euch kurz mal fest. Also das heißt, du hast ein Boosted Board, das sehr teuer war, das du nicht kontrollieren kannst und mit dem du auch nicht auf der freien Fläche fahren darfst. Wie sieht die Zukunft aus? Wie kommst du aus diesem Dilemma raus? Ich hab mich schon abgesichert in dem Sinne, dass ich wahrscheinlich verkaufen werde, wenn das nicht funktioniert. Ansonsten habe ich mir gerade den Helm besorgt, in meiner Größe, mein Kopfumfang sind 56 cm, das ist ganz normal, das klingt wenig, aber ich habe es gegoogelt, es ist normal. Ich weiß nicht, ob das wenig oder viel ist. Und damit fahre ich einfach jetzt durch die Gegend, rasant durch Köln, bis ich Strafe zahlen muss, bis zu 1000 Euro und Punkte in Flensburg bekommen kann. Und dann, wenn ich schlechte Erfahrungen, es kommt ein bisschen darauf an, wie meine erste Fahrerfahrung wird. Weil ich weiß, du bist ein Prankster, du bist ein Bulli, wenn ich in die Schule, wenn ich in die Schule komme und meine Jacke in meinen Spind hänge, weiss ich, steht daneben, mache ich die Spindtür zu und hinter der Spindtür steht ich stehe da! Na, auch schon da? Hat dir das Schirt deine Mama rausgelegt oder was?
Wieder auf deinem schwulen Board gekommen? Auf deinem Faggot-Board? Und dann hast du auch so eine Entourage die ganze Zeit lacht.
Einen schwarzen, einen dicken, ach so.
Wegen Diversity, auch eine rothaarige Frau.
Schmerst du mich ein? Aber weißt du, in dieser Geschichte, wer gewinnt am Ende? Der mit dem Boosted Board.
Das stimmt. Der in den Spinn gesperrt wird., wer gewinnt am Ende? Der mit dem Boosted-Bord. Das stimmt.
Der in den Spind gesperrt wird. Und der Bulli hat am Ende irgendwie den Biff von Back to the Future, der am Ende mein Auto. Moment, das heißt aber, dass ich mich morgen früh hier schön auf dem Hof mit einem Tee in der Hand gemütlich hinsetzen kann und erwarten darf, dass jede Sekunde Stefan Tee hoch aufrecht in senkrechten 90-Grad-Körperhaltung und sich ständig entschuldigend um die Ecke schießt. Sorry, mein Kind.
Lassen Sie mein Kind. Sorry, sorry, Feuer, sorry.
Wie war das möglich?
Genau so fährst du durch die Gegend.
Dann komme ich mit so einem großen Streichholz an.
Das heißt, morgen kommst du?
Ich werde hier so, oh.
Morgen kommst du, morgen kommst du. Ja, nein. Ich werde, nein, du hast jetzt einen Helm und du hast das Ding. Ich muss erst üben, fahren üben. Ich muss erst üben. Steht das auf der Verpackung drauf, stand es im Playboy-Artikel. Man muss aber erst üben. Ja, bei Playboy vielleicht nicht, weil das sind die coolen, aber auf der Verpackung stand Lebensgefahr. Ich weiß nicht, ob es auf die Batterie bezogen war oder auf das Vehikel an sich, aber da stand Lebensgefahr. Man muss ja immer diesen Batterieschacht wegziehen, weißt du, da hat man immer so eine Lasche. Und normalerweise hast du einfach so einen Pfeil drauf, da stand aber Lebensgefahr. Ja, und wie lädst du das Ding? Am Steckdose einfach? Steckdose, was lädst du von der Steckdose? Und da tust du einen Akku rein und steckst den Akku wieder rein. Ja, 12 Kilometer, such deine Schwachstellen. Kommst du da überhaupt hierher? Nein. Und warum wohnst du denn weg? Am Arsch der Welt. Ich muss mit der Bahn fahren und das die ganze Zeit unterm Arm haben. Und dann kann ich... Was? Du kannst nicht mal von hier, von hier, von hier, von deiner Wohnung zur Arbeit fahren? Wie soll das gehen? Ich wohne in Deutz. Das ist ja die einzige Strecke, die dich überhaupt bewegst in deinem Leben. Flonti. Und dir fährst du nicht mal, wozu hast du das Ding? Lass mich los. Lass mich einfach von meinem Sp runter, kurz lass mich die Spinntür zumachen Ey, ich will dich einfach nur einmal mit dem Ding fahren sehen und wenn wir da über den Rhein joggen müssen, von mir aus machen wir uns einen schönen Tag am Samstag Nachmittag gehen wir mal zum Rhein und du braust da hin zu zweit, kann man zu zweit ich setze mich auf den Lenker du, ich kann nicht so auf die Schulter nehmen und dann fahren wir rum ich dachte mir auch, dass ich auf der Rheinbrücke damit teste, weil das eine coole, gerade Strecke. Aber ich glaube, dass wenn ich dann mich hinlege, dass das Rad, dass das dann unter einer Bezäunung von der Rheinbrücke runterrutscht, das wäre so gut. Tizze, teste, Trends. Oh nein! Gute Arbeit Originals. Das fand ich gut. Das fand ich gut. Das finde ich auch lustig. Schade. Das heißt, ich werde dich wahrscheinlich nie auf dem Ding nehmen. Ich komme morgen damit an. Morgen oder übermorgen komme ich damit an. Das heißt, du nimmst das Ding dann aus dem Spin, das sechs Kilo schwere Teil, trägst du dann irgendwie zur U-Bahn, fährst mit dem riesigen sperrigen Ding in U-Bahn und dann von der U-Bahn stellst du dich an der U-Bahn-Haltestelle auf das Ding, fährst die 200 Meter hierher und dafür hast du deinen Helm aufgesetzt und deine Frisur ruiniert und siehst den Rest des Tages scheiße aus. Danke für diese Empathie, die ich dir nicht zugetraut hätte. Meine Frisur, du hast diese mir ist Kopfbedeckung scheißegal, Frisur. Ich sehe ja, wie du jeden Tag vorm Spiegel stehst und dann mit deinem Got to be, mit deiner blauen Sprayflasche dann so. Nein, ich benutze ein L'Oreal. Klassisch L'Oreal. Du hast diese, sieht immer okay aus, Frisur, okay? Sieht immer super aus. Dankeschön. Sieht immer richtig klasse aus. Fesch. Weißt du, und ich muss mich da in Abraken, weil meine Haare, ich weiß nicht, ob Leute das Problem haben, herzlich willkommen zu meinem Körper, again, meine Haare, die haben so eine Teddybär-Dichte. Heißt, wenn ich meine Haare nicht, wenn ich die wasche und dann föhne, dann stehen die so ab, in alle Richtungen, wie so ein Teddybär-Fell, wie so Synthetikhaare, die man so eingesetzt hat, die aber nicht die richtige Konsistenz von Haaren haben, sondern die so ein bisschen wie so typische China-Materialien. Du hast dann keine Strähnen und Schöpfe mehr, sondern nur einzelne Haare. Nö, einfach nach oben weg. Einfach in alle Richtungen, wie so eine Sonne. Wie so ein Igel. Wie willst du das lösen mit deinem Helm? Stell dir mal vor, du siehst dann irgendwie eine sexy Girl, sexy Mädel, siehst du dann am Einufer, braust vorbei, sie kriegt direkt Eisprung, irgendwie ist bereit und dann Helm ab und du siehst aus wie Günther Knapp. Ja, aber dann halte ich mir den Busselbord hoch und dann dachte sie, oh, oh, oh, oh, kann ich mich gleich wieder treffen? Kann ich hinten draufsteigen? Ne, leider nur eine Person zugelassen, ansonsten Lebensgefahr. Und das Ding ist verboten. Oh, oh, du bist ja richtig kriminell. Wo muss man sich denn anstellen, um mit dem was schlafen zu können? Da hinten bei der großen Schlange, die ganzen Frauen, die hier stehen? Ja, genau da müsst ihr hier anstellen, Ladies! Du hast noch nie eine Frau gesehen in deinem Leben, oder? Sind das diese kleineren Menschen? Ja, naja, manche, manche. Diese sehr kleinen Menschen, die auf diesen Dreirädern rumfahren,
die haben so Gepferden
und die haben Helme auf,
wenn die auf diesen Dreirädern fahren.
Unsere Linda, die Praktikantin.
Linda, die heute beim Burger King Essen gebracht hat.
Hier die,
der Markus hat jetzt eine Frau bekommen.
Eine kleine Frau. Ja, nee, das ist wieder, das sind Kinder, glaube ich. Das ist wieder was anderes. Die Luna, die mit dem Halsband immer rumläuft? Nee, das ist ein Hund. Nein, du zeigst auf eine Mülltolle, Stefan, so wird das nichts. Also, vielleicht schickt doch mal ein paar nette Bilder von jungen, kecken Damen, vielleicht von euch selbst, wenn ihr selber Kekedamen seid und Stefan einmal auf seinem Boosted-Bord durch Köln.
Es werden wieder nur Fotos von dir sein, weil du dich wieder reinschmuggelst.
Du, Fotos von dir im Kleid mit, du bist ein richtig tolles Mädchen.
Okay, wir hören hier auf an der Stelle. Vielen Dank fürs Zuhören, bis nächste Woche.
Nächste Woche schreiben wir wieder. Macht's gut.
Ciao, wie Mabou, alles übersteuert die ganze Zeit.